how to go red let's bury that and
welcome to some dying light this game is
awesome
it's parkour made zambese there hasn't
been a better combos and turkey and
sandwich all right so this is dining
light not so dying like they should call
it so yeah you can do all kinds of cool
stuff like 360 noscopes I don't think
you can do that actually
we'll see it tells me I need to go in
here good you hear about a man who's a
critical supply route that's go on the
[ __ ] and we need to clear our Scouts use
it day and night
oh now I'm gonna do a maintenance run
you'll be arming some of our traps they
help us keep the root clip but you need
to hurry we're running out of daylight
you don't want to be out there on your
own once the Sun Goes Down good luck hey
why don't just you do it
you're just gonna sit in that chair
aren't you really alright well I guess I
gotta go then kind of do all the hard
work here your leg man what that's rude
man wanna get yourself caught in and -
we still need you here
haha my name is Antoine all right that's
nice I look nothing like in it
no four in front of my damage all right
what do we got
alright let's use it oh my gosh dr. da
and it's Oh God activate trap
chose said zombies just as I like them I
need to prepare a car alarm all right
that's cool so now we can try you see
there's room see you see you can use
already just run like an idiot like I do
and once free pokemons
there's no Pokemon stupid zambese never
realized all right what do I got later
news thanks all right what's next
I love the parkour in this game it feels
really nice like it it's really flow
super well I got Bradley you don't even
have to think about it but it still
feels awesome oh god oh god oh god oh
god
I like no big them oh this seems like a
sign class hey leave that man alone
oh I said leave him alone that doesn't
mean bite me you bald it be buting egg
I'll sit down good night sit down I say
wonderful all right what was it what do
you want nice toast when you repay the
favor
wait how okay eight bucks man you broke
I risk my life for eight bucks too bad
yourself saying in there then such you
get eight bucks give me a break
whoa that is some nasty [ __ ] rah
you see tingling feeling when you hear
them behind you oh god oh god I got it
higher education spike what spitters
what who did that
oh god what the hell if you get a spit
on man please ask first there we go
that's what you get you fatty fat fat I
can actively uh okay cool cool with that
it I'm fine yeah I'm going over there
and slumps train yard whoa what the hell
am i doing hopefully shout all right
another trap let's do it
or is it now this isn't it oh man
the whole goddamn district went down
what the hell's going on what what just
happened oh the trap okay come on leave
it are any of these just um I mean I'm
just gonna open this box it's a great
box may know how out take a poke ball
and get out of my way
oh oh god oh god you gotta go hey oh God
so many bad I am mega
oh god this is dammit boots come on all
right
oh damn there's no being
all right we can do it come on it's
getting night I don't like that
whoa whoa whoa someone touched my butt I
swear to god someone did it this gotta
be the last one now this is the place Oh
awesome listen keep tapping gotta head
now didn't get that at home
well I always better happy now it seems
to be black and runny oh god they're
gonna attract them marte are we gonna do
this Indiana jones-style hi don't kick
each other dogs bike I got some fries up
to me sorry
Bobo let's raise Emmys ah this is too
much for my poor heart
ah dad dad ah oh they're everywhere
the my mate the my name just sent a
mirror Oh back off spun and sat down
activate some traps man there we go come
on
open up please what you telling me this
now why don't look back don't look back
by those back I look back I look back
oh I don't think it would be scary
come on I mean I was gay all right I
love this game
I can't wait for more of it to come out
this game is so awesome I really love it
hope you enjoyed watching that's it stay
awesome